[Music]
story for you guys i think you're gonna
like it
here it is i got it i got it all right
this this story is beautiful
this is one right here
brian thomas wants his 70 thousand tick
tock followers to know all about his
battle with monkey pox
imagine like i know these people are
just trying to make it like less you
know
stigmatized
yeah you're just openly bragging that
you have gay sex disease i just want
people to know that watch this there's a
shyamalan twist too this is a manageable
illness it's temporary it's not
permanent however it is a virus that's
disproportionately affected gay men so
far brian believes he caught monkey pox
during a pride event in wilton manor's
florida there was a lot oh that's the
gayest sentence i've heard that is that
that is the gay city in florida
that is the gay without bro that wasn't
what's it matters when i was a kid used
to be a black neighborhood and then
that's one of those we were just talking
about earlier was gentrify the gays
gentrified it yeah and then all the nice
restaurants are there now and [ __ ]
it's all the big money gays that live
there that's by the way that was the
gayest sentence anyone's ever said right
that's disproportionately at a pride
event in wilton manor's florida that's
the gayest that's ever said affected gay
men so far brian believes he caught
monkey pox during a pride event in
wilton manors florida there was lots of
people lots of just um close contact
with lots of people and i think yeah is
that what kind of contact you had i have
a feeling a lot of unprotected gay sex
yeah
that's most likely where i got it brian
grew his social media platform
discussing his experience as an hr
[ __ ] guy he's a nurse no that's no no
no that's you guys are about to miss the
twist hold on there's a twist social
media platform discussing his experience
as an hiv positive nurse in baltimore oh
okay
this is the gayest what
gayest story in america it's this one
right here i'm sorry but is that allowed
to be gay you're allowed to be gay nurse
shut up what
are you allowed to be a medical
professional if you have a shave yeah i
think the kid the kid why wouldn't you
be allowed i mean you should still be
alive
why wouldn't you i would sue the [ __ ]
out of a hospital if they did not
disclose to me their nurse no no they
don't have they don't have to unless the
nurse isn't bleeding on you
[ __ ] that don't touch me oh my god jesus
christ he's working with needles yeah i
get that he's going to happen one
accident
all i'm saying is you can't find me a
nurse that doesn't have hiv is that a
tall order around here now
baltimore no wilton matters either
social media platform discussing his
experience as an hiv positive nurse in
baltimore now he's using it to spread
the word about monkey pox of course
we're like oh like it's not going to be
that big of a deal it's just being
sensationalized and it's definitely not
going to happen to me
and um you know i am proof that it can
happen how are you the only way he got
monkey pox by the way the only thing on
monkey pox is if he had
unprotected sex at wilton manors right
so therefore a man with hiv
was having unprotected sex you already
got hiv
i don't know if it's necessarily
unprotected sex because it's a virus i'm
sure you could maybe catch it from you
know a little bit of that sucking a
little bit pretty joking sure a little
bit of making out i'm pretty sure it's
more of a sex snowballing i know all the
details look i'm just saying
some shrimping
and an increasing number of people in
tampa bay are catching it so far they're
marsh
you have something you want to tell us
yes i have monkey pox
where'd you catch it i don't have monkey
pox i just have toxoplasmosis oh okay
i don't have monkey pox we just have hpv
i just have a cat brain demon
there have been five cases in pinellas
county and two in polk usa two in polk
oh no is it me and you i hope not [ __ ]
deaf health doctor thomas younash says
monkeypox cases have rarely ever spread
out of africa and it
well here we are may have managed to
mutate to become a little bit more
infectious and more well adapted to
human beings unash says monkey pox is
spread through close contact which makes
it much less transmissible than covid19
oh yes so it's close contact with any of
the rashes or the pox so it is it isn't
just you don't think that you don't
think the butt [ __ ]
i'm sure it's not helping what i'm
saying is i don't think it's
necessarily unprotected sex like you
could just
literally be sharing the same bedding
share a towel
all the time
and i hear you and you're right i'm not
gonna deny what you're saying because
that is true it's not just sex
do you think that that man wasn't having
unprotected sex in wilton manners with
hiv do you really believe that
probably not okay that's that's just my
only question there's aren't there bug
chasers in that whole thing
i'm sure so unlike uh covet which you
know has developed to a point where now
where uh one person in a room can infect
everybody and a hundred people in a room
all at once this thing requires really
pretty darn close intimate contact and
up until now intimate contact merge
that would
that would involve butt [ __ ]
i just read here that you can get it
from just
sharing a towel yeah yeah you know who
said that somebody with monkey pox they
don't want to get caught that they were
[ __ ] somebody
who is that is that the butt dog is that
is that the butt is that the butt repair
doctor that we found remember that i
must have caught it from somebody's
towel
is that the butt repair doctor remember
the guy from the postmates commercial
then again i don't know me personally if
you said oh no i caught monkey box i was
sharing a towel with somebody i'd go
ew you should have told me you were
having butt sex i know i would have
rather hurt a towel with a person's
[ __ ] it's weird right i would rather
i mean unless you're married to them or
something you have one no [ __ ] that even
if you're married
get your own towel
you could afford a towel
um
what was i oh uh you want to just roll
through the break and get out here
literally yeah good uh because i don't
want to do that do the brake thing
uh so let's finish this now there
haven't been any deaths associated with
the virus in the u.s initial symptoms
can include fever fatigue and muscle
[ __ ]
flakes eventually patients develop a
rash with blisters that can be very
painful i've got one right here
and that's what brian is dealing with
and he wants the public to avoid it if
possible and it's very it is possible
it's super possible
scary but um
you know it i think we're just very
burnt out we're like okay it's just
another thing but we need to take it
seriously
again i don't know you didn't take it
seriously you got hiv you didn't take
something seriously twice you're not
taking any of this seriously it seems
this is all a joke to you sir
this whole thing's a joke